From software's new game is open-world
There will be significant RPG elements
its allegedly the largest project today's and
It's called
Elden ring
Elden rings development started just as development for Dark Souls 3 DLC ended
As of today that's more than 2 years of development. And while we don't have a release date for this
multi-platform title I
Would put my money on early 2020. This is considering that from software often launches new titles in March and
also that Sekiro is
Likely to get DLC later this year and unlike Sekiro, Miyazaki states that Elden Ring puts more focus on
RPG elements, which I know is gonna please all of us. That means he says "A wide variety of weapons,
Magic and ways to engage enemies with the strategies that suit you."  "More variety - says Miyazaki -
Even when compared to the Dark Souls series." And you want to know why that's incredible because that kind of diversity
Matches really well with the fact that this game is open-world for the first time
Miyazaki does say that there are many definitions to the term "open world"
But that Fromsoftware has simply tried their hand at creating a game with a large
Open field to play in a world that yes still contains
intricately designed levels such as
multi-layered castles and such he says and I can only assume that this means we'll be able to
Tackle those areas in whatever order we like
Which again could be incredible because whenever I play Dark Souls, I tried a sequence break as fast as possible
I always try to deck out my character with unique gear from all over the game
not just the gear that's at the start of the game and
From an RPG point of view linear progression has always held back
Souls to an extent when you think about it
however
It really does sound like
Elden Ring will afford the player the opportunity to travel to any corner of the world from the get go and
get this
Miyazaki says this is without a doubt our biggest title yet in terms of sheer volume and
he says that the scale of the world and the narrative to accompany it matches that and
he goes on to say maybe as expected the game will still include intense boss fights character creation and
Perhaps most importantly a focus on overcoming challenges
It sounds like they haven't given in to the people crying for an easy mode just yet
which is good news after all the game is about the will or the ambition of
Mankind says Miyazaki and this alliance with the press release that I received which stated that an
Adventure awaits the brave and the gallant all this wording really aligns with the heroic visuals that you see in the trailer
There's this
nobility of the self in this trailer and
That's in stark contrast to a lot of Dark Souls visuals. For example
which often emphasizes the worthlessness of the self instead of the nobility of the self and
Misaki said that
they wanted to create a title that's full of the things that they weren't able to do in the Dark Souls series and that includes
breaking out into a whole new mythos a body of mythology that is written by George R. R. Martin and
You can tell Miyazaki is this huge fan of the guy he writes that George provided incredible?
Stimulus for the team that George wrote characters drama and mystical elements that would go on to shape Elden rings
Presentation. So to me this sounds like George laid the foundations and
Miyazaki and his team built upon those foundations. And so we arrived finally at the trailer
Let me point out some of the curious aspects of it five arms spring from the darkness
Arms that have these nobly protrusions and an extra elbow almost as if they're sort of curved outwards from this
Character's own back. They support this crowned man or woman. It's hard to say as he or she raises a twitching
larger hand
Shift on to their own arm. This is likely Sekiro's lost arm. Just kidding
This seems like a sort of dark ritual one that sets a pretty horrific tone for the game going forward.
The Elden ring says Miyazaki is the name given to a mysterious concept that defines the world itself
So it's this cosmic
Unimaginable force and what we see in the trailer is its shattering presumably at the hands of this blacksmith
and I'm willing to bet that he's a sort of blacksmith deity, which is a concept that
exists not only in North mythology
Not only in Celtic mythology
But even in Dark Souls as well and this shattering could also go on to explain the games logo
Four rings of fire which are out of sync with one another
Speaking of which the word Elden may not simply mean old or ancient or elder
But it could be echoing the old Norse term elder
Meaning fire this could explain the burning sky that we see in the scene to follow
In this scene the crimson haired woman reattaches a sort of brass arm
which is either locked on with magnetic force or magic because there is not much there to attach to and
It's a parallel to the character in the first scene who is grafting on an arm of flesh
Which may be a significant parallel in the end on the other hand of the woman though. It doesn't look that good
She's sporting blackened flesh and a sheen of rust that is glinting in the sunlight
Also note the parallel between the rust on her arm and the cracking of the blacksmith's
It's almost as if they're all made of some sort of stone, and I assume there are sort of divine entity
Immediately after this this warrior thrusts his spear into the belly of his foe and the elden ring shatters right after this
Along with a dialogue about it being shattered by someone or something
I take this to sort of mean that the blacksmith probably isn't the only reason the ring is being undone and
With every blow that the blacksmith strikes his own flesh cracks
So too does the flesh of this ashen haired woman who appears to also be holding the hilt of another blacksmith hammer in this scene?
The two aren't just connected with each other. They're also synced with the ring and they're all
shattering together the rest of the cast are connected as well as
We fly along with this spear as if were attached to it with a GoPro take note of the fallen corpses in the background
They're the same fallen corpses, which are present in this scene with the kneeling tusk helmed Knight
it's very likely that this was who speak I thrust his spear into and
You even see something that could be the task knight's sword in the background
this guy as well has crimson hair and I assume this signifies a sort of
shared faction between these two characters
Obviously the shattering of this ring has
implications for the entire cycle of the world and I can only assume that our
playable
Created character will appear after this crucial moment
this is so shattering that a new world order likely has to be defined and
Since the theme of the game is the ambition of man
Maybe the gods have become vulnerable and it's our time to shine
Or something like that. It sounds pretty familiar for from software with one final strike
the blacksmith breaks the ring bringing it raining down atop the two cracked beings and
A cracked logo appears as well
So all of this pretty much aligns with the first set of leaks that we received where we discussed the game by its
Internal working title great Rudin it was open-world
it involves visiting kingdoms and it does seem to be
inspired by North mythology in retrospect that video is more worth checking out than I anticipated it being and
on the note of North mythology
We should devote some time to the likely cultural inspirations that are present in Elden ring as well
But you should bear in mind that unlike some titles like god of war for example
from software rarely takes concepts in their entirety
Instead they're more inspired by these cultures and it often feels like they build ideas outwards from them
So for example in this trailer and in the leaks, it's likely that they're building off of North and Celtic mythologies
while I was streaming the announcement live on twitch a bunch of people drew parallels to and i'm gonna butcher the name, but
Nuada a god with an arm of silver that was forged for him by one of three gods of
Craftsmanship and also Luke a man with a spear that always hits its mark
They are all of the "Tuatha Dé Danann"  the tribe of the Gods
These noble beings are in opposition to the "Fomorians"
Supernatural beings that represents darker powers and already it's possible. We see this same sort of contrast in the trailer
I'd also like to draw your attention to this character who has a helmet sporting too angelic wings
This is a popular visual for the Valkyrie of North mythology
Valkyrie will warrior women who descended upon the battlefield and
Judged the Fallen and if you were deemed to have died bravely in battle
Then the Valkyrie would take you to Valhalla a Hall where you would dine and eventually fight alongside Odin himself
There's more like the Celtic knot imagery
Norse hammers
But for now, it's probably best to take these likely inspirations with a grain of salt
The only thing we don't know at this point is about the gameplay
sekito in my opinion set a new standard for combat systems in these games and if
Anything I desperately hope that they took on some of these combat innovations during development
It's kind of hard to go back to souls now
Anyway, subscribe and ring the bell so you can be the first to learn about the gameplay whenever it crops up and I'll see you
next time